Israël a évidemment le droit de se
défendre face au terrorisme les civils
doivent être épargnés la réponse
militaire doit se faire dans le respect
du droit international notamment du
droit international humanitaire les
populations ne doivent pas payer pour
les crimes des terroristes à Gaza nous
devons regarder en face l'ampleur de la
catastrophe humanitaire en cours l'accès
au services essentiels est quasiment
interrompu l'eau la nourriture le
foulement
la distribution d'aide exige une trêve
humanitaire qui pourra mener à un cess
le
[Musique]
feu pourquoi la France est-elle
incapable de dénoncer avec la même force
les crimes de guerre commis par le Hamas
et ce commis par le gouvernement de
netanah pourquoi n'cart pas comme elle a
pu le faire par le passé par la voix de
jacquesirac la voix de la paix au pri
avvez choisi d'abandonner la position
historique de la France qui a fait sa
grandeur et qui a permis qu'elle soit
audible dans les ténèbres des relations
internationales la France est désormais
montré du doigt dans le monde et par les
peuples cela doit cesser membrees du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU la France
doit peser de tout son poids pour
permettre l'adoption d'une résolution
exigeant un cesser le feu pour arrêter
cette escalade meurtrière je reconnais
bien volontiers la complexité à protéger
les civils car le Hamas toujours plus
enclin à ligne se sert de la population
civile comme bouclier humain mais la
grandeur de l'armée d'Israël sera
justement de respecter ces règles que
les terroristes du Hamas ont eux
honteusement et lâchement bafoué voilà
chers collègues d'extrême gauche ce qui
différencie la civilisation de la
barbarie voilà ce qui différencie une
armée régulière d'une organisation
terroriste voilà pourquoi on ne demande
pas à des terroristes de cesser le feu
mais de déposer les armes et de lib les
otages c'est tout nous appelons au
respect du droit international et
demandons des négociations immédiates
pour un cesser le veux comme il appelle
Antonio gterz nous réclamons la levée
totale du blocus de Gaza cruel inhumain
illégal nous demandons aux autorités
françaises et européennes au niveau
international devrait à la création de
couloirs humanitaires pour acheminer les
secours d'urgence il y a urgence pour
les Gazaoui d'abord le risque d'une
escalade incontrôlée pouvant conduire à
un embrasement général derrière le Hamas
il y a le hzbollah derrière le hbollah
il y a l'Iran derrière l'Iran il y a la
Russie et la Chine le deuxième risque
majeur c'est en effet celui d'un
anéantissement massif des populations
civiles utilisé par les uns comme des
boucliers humains et par les autres
comme l'exitoire d'une tentation de
vengeance pour reprendre l'expression
préoccupante du Premier ministre
israélien